dazu seien herzlich willkommen zur zdf
arte live mit ihren live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
jeden tag gibt es neue entwicklungen in
der korona krise und ausgerechnet an dem
tag an dem der impfstoff von biontech
und kaiser in der eu zugelassen wird
machen viele eu-staaten die grenzen zu
großbritannien dicht denn dort ist eine
neue mutierte variante des virus
entdeckt worden
und als konsequenz lassen jetzt viele
länder flugzeuge nicht mehr bei sich
landen waren dürfen nicht mehr wenn
ärmelkanal gebracht werden das heißt
großbritannien ist quasi abgeschottet
die große frage ist jetzt wie gefährlich
ist diese neue virusvariante eigentlich
und ist diese abriegelung der insel
eigentlich gerechtfertigt dass folge
heute besprechen mit dem biologen und
mikrobiologen andreasberg thaler von der
österreichischen akademie der
wissenschaften und danach schalten wir
nach london zu unserer korrespondentin
diana zimmermann sprechen dort über die
politischen auswirkungen dieser blockade
oder dieser absperrung dieser
sicherheitsvorkehrungen wie das die
politiker nennen fragen kommentare bitte
gerne in die dafür vorgesehenen spalten
oder annette erfreute - live at zdf.de
für alle die gerade in der app gucken
und neben mir sehen wir ihn schon in
wien den mikrobiologen andreasberg
thaler von der österreichischen akademie
der wissenschaften schönen abend einen
schönen guten haben dass wir ganz
wichtige frage die sich viele jetzt
stellen ja was ist das besondere an
dieser variante dass viren mutieren
haben den letzten zehn bis zwölf monaten
ja doch alle mittlerweile gelernt
das ist korrekt also mir dann sicher top
besonders auch das scoreboard wir uns
zwei die mode ihren kontinuierlich das
heißt sie bauen fehler eigenen ihre
erbsubstanz und das beobachten wir im
prinzip seit jänner
man kann auch dazu sagen dass das carbon
wir uns zwei im durchschnitt weniger
schnell montiert als zb das grippevirus
weil im fall von saas columbus 2 haben
wir ungefähr zwei mutationen pro monat
die sich ansammeln und das heißt bitte
was selbst
das besondere an der mutation die wir
jetzt vorliegen haben genau also in dem
fall haben jetzt eine variante vorliegen
die zum ersten mal im september in
england entdeckt wurde
und ich glaube es sind drei aspekte die
diese variante besonders machen oder
zumindestens für erhöhtes interesse
sorgen gerechtfertigt das erste ist dass
diese variante überdurchschnittlich
viele mutationen angesammelt hat das
heißt wir sprechen von 17 mutationen
genetische veränderungen die die
wertstoffe betreffen und noch
zusätzliche weitere sechs mutationen
das ist der erste aspekt der zweite
aspekt ist dass manche dieser mutationen
schon im labor in anderen zusammenhängen
untersucht wurden und da gibt es eine
handvoll mutationen die tatsächlich
zumindestens unter laborbedingungen zum
beispiel die infektiosität des virus
erhöhen zu scheinen
und der dritte aspekt warum dass diese
variante aus aus aus dem vereinigten
königreich solches interesse hervorruft
ist das pädagogen england den eindruck
gewonnen haben dass diese variante sich
schneller verbreitet in der population
als andere varianten
ich glaube gerade der letzte punkt ist
etwas da muss man ein bisschen mit
vorsicht das genießen weil da gibt es
unterschiedlichste begründungen warum es
zu dieser schnellen verbreitung kommt
jetzt könnten die mutationen des virus
sein aber es könnte noch begleitumstände
seien inklusive zufälle bei super
spreading events das heißt wir müssen
hier auf dieses phänomen was wir uns
gerade beobachten wo er auch doch
drastische konsequenzen gezogen werden
mit größter vorsicht gucken wir reden
gleich darüber weiter was das bedeuten
könnte herbert thaler aber mein kollege
pablo salahi hat eine kurze
zusammenfassung von dem gemacht was hier
über diese virus mutation bis jetzt
wissen ein zahlencode bereitet europa
derzeit große sorge bei 117 so haben
wissenschaftler die mutierte variante
des corona virus genannt doch wie
gefährlich ist sie wirklich der
chefgeologe der charité christian
drosten warnt vor alarmismus
und verweist darauf dass die mutation
bereits in mehreren ländern vorgekommen
ist ohne große auffälligkeiten zuletzt
in den niederlanden
das muss also in holland schon vor
anfang dezember angekommen sein
es ist aber nicht hochgekocht dort ist
es virus hat sich gar nicht groß
vermehrt und so wird das in vielen
anderen ländern auch sein ich bin jetzt
alles andere als beunruhigt was das
angeht
britische wissenschaftler dagegen
sprechen von einer wesentlich höheren
ansteckungsrate wie jeremy frau als
direktor des wellcome trust einer der
einflussreichsten infektionsexperten der
welt es sieht aus dass es ansteckender
ist und sich in gemeinschaften schneller
ausbreitet auch in deutschland könnte
bei 117 bereits zirkulieren
und darüber sprechen wir heute abend ist
in österreichischen virologen und
immunologen andreasberg thaler von der
österreichischen akademie der
wissenschaften
jetzt haben wir gerade zwei meinungen so
ein bisschen gehört herr professor
draußen macht sich nicht so viele sorgen
der kollege in großbritannien scheint
ein bisschen besorgt zu sein wie ist
denn ihre einschätzung
ich will mich eher intim großen seen
ich glaube es ist jener diskrepanz
einerseits wie so oft in dieser pandemie
dass man wissenschaftlich noch nicht
ausreichend bescheid weiß nicht die
endgültigen beweise hat dass sehr vieles
dem zufall auch geschuldet sein kann
und ja gleichzeitig sie mutationen die
dieser häufung noch selten gefunden
wurden
und das natürlich auch dann die
schwierigkeit der politik greift man
maßnahmen ja nein und in welcher form
ich glaube ich bin jetzt auch nicht
extrem besorgt ich glaube aber dass es
uns einen fingerzeig gibt dass die party
unberechenbar ist dass wir uns auch
forsch auf der forschungsseite gut
aufstellen müssen das war wirklich eng
matschig monitoren die sich das virus
verändert damit wir dann auch möglichst
frühzeitig darauf reagieren können
vielleicht können sie uns jetzt mal zum
kleinen einführungskurs virologie geben
diese mutationen die wir ja jetzt doch
schon beobachtet haben von denen wir
gehört haben
da stellt man sich als laie ein bisschen
die frage warum machen die viren das
hier gibt es auch die frage von besser
auf youtube was ist die ursache für die
mutation und wie weit können diese gehen
wie sehr kann das virus sich verändern
können sie das mal kurz erklären warum
passiert das überhaupt man kann sich das
folgendermaßen vorstellen das genom von
cars 2 das enthält 30.000 buchstaben die
eine lange linie quasi ergeben
man kann sich vorstellen wie ein langes
wort in einem kleineren heftigen und das
muss sehr oft repliziert werden also
quasi kopiert werden und in diesem
kopiervorgang läuft ständig was das
heißt von diesen 30.000 buchstaben kommt
immer wieder mal vor dass ein buchstaben
verdreht wird vertauscht wird genau
ausfällt und das sind alles quasi
genetische veränderung die wir sehen die
wir gemeinden als mutation bezeichnen
das läuft konkret so ab dass das virus
hat einer stoffe die dann an dieses
virus genommen
und dann in kopie davon erstellen und
was auf den ersten blick vielleicht
nicht so intuitiv ist aber dass wir was
benötigt diese fehler nämlich das virus
muss ich ständig ist zu 100 prozent
abhängig von seinem wird und muss
dementsprechend sich auch flexibel auf
neue gegebenheiten einstellen sei es zum
beispiel unterstützt unterschiedliche
spezies immunantworten sei es auch
therapien vielleicht und in dem fall das
ist eigentlich ganz normal dass rna
viren mutieren und sich verändern
es wurde sogar gezeigt vor einigen
jahren für polio virus eine sehr
spannende studie dass wenn man diese
kopiermaschine des virus zwingt keine
fehler zu machen dann ist das virus
massiv abgeschwächt
das zeigt dass diese fehlerrate gerade
wichtig ist für die evolution des virus
und diese fehler an sich sie neben dem
ersten moment mal zufällig das heißt das
ist nicht gerichtet das virus hat keinen
größeren plan wie es ist ein überleben
sichert sondern dieser mutationen
entstehen
total zufällig und willkürlich das heißt
das geht dann endeffekt ums überleben
des virus also sich immer wieder an
passt ein neuer begebenheiten und
versucht einfach der sich selber zu
optimieren vielleicht jetzt haben wir
auch schon gelernt
diese virus variante scheint nicht ganz
so an stall so ansteckend zu sein ja
aber zu nicht so schweren
krankheitsverläufen zu führen ist das
auch so ein überlebensmechanismus von so
einer virusattacke dass das versucht den
wird so lange wie möglich am leben zu
halten
ich meine das ist jetzt mal theorie im
ersten im ersten blick dass man
natürlich sicher warten könnte für das
perfekte virus das werde versuchen
möglichst keine krankheit zu verursachen
oder keine schwerwiegende und
gleichzeitig sehr infektiös zu sein oder
sich irgendwie in wird zu verstecken
vielleicht ein beispiel des herpes
simplex das quasi diese klassischen
viele blasen hervorruft dieses virus hat
geschafft dass es sich in bestimmten
nervenzellen des körpers verstecken kann
und ab und an taucht einmal auf und man
hat viele blasen wenn man nicht sonst
immun geschwächt ist das ist eigentlich
für ihn wäre es evolutionär gesehen dass
das ziel in dem fall jetzt bei dem stars
krone wir uns zwei haben wir einerseits
ein sehr infektiös des virus das
gleichzeitig eine
moderate aber doch auf jeden fall
vorhandene eigenschaft hat um für
erschwert erkrankungen zu sorgen und die
frage die man sich natürlich stellt aber
nicht wirklich beantworten kann zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt wie verändert sich
das saatvirus zwei weiter kann man
erwarten dass es sich zum beispiel
abschwächt in der menschlichen
population
das war schon spannend dass sie jetzt
das herpesvirus was irgendwie niemand so
richtig gerne mal quasi als den popstar
der viren bezeichnet haben weil das sich
so gut angepasst haben wir ja was
gelernt heute abend hier ist eine sehr
spannende frage auch von dori auf
youtube wie und wer entdeckte die
mutation also wird das die ganze zeit
beobachtet und sequenziert dass man
schaut wie sich das verändert oder war
das eher zufall
also man muss sagen mutationen kann man
finden indem man diese virus gelungen
aus liest heißt sequenziert und das
macht jedes land verfolgt eine andere
strategie
im fall vom vereinigten königreich haben
die schon sehr frühzeitig relativ viel
geld in die hand genommen über 20
millionen pfund die haben auch eine
eines der größten sequenziert zentren
aller welt reizt das sänger da institut
dh die produzieren überdurchschnittlich
viele videosequenzen ein durchschnitt
zurzeit kommt aus england monatlich
circa 10.000 neue virus genome heraus
und weltweit haben wir über 270.000
virus genommen mittlerweile sequenzieren
auch veröffentlicht das heißt ich glaube
sie schon auch dieser strategie zu
verdanken dass man wahrscheinlich früher
als sonst auf diese variante aufmerksam
geworden ist jetzt gibt es ja eine frage
zum thema impfstoff und mutationen also
stellen wir immer wieder fest dass
zuschauer innen eine sache beobachten
eine neue sache passiert und dann
versuchen sie einen zusammenhang
herzustellen hier zum beispiel georg
minkenberg auf youtube der fragt ist es
wirklich zufall dass die virus mutation
in einem land ausbricht wo seit kurzem
der neue impfstoff zugelassen wurde von
auch schon einige tausend menschen damit
geimpft worden sind oder hat es
vielleicht etwas mit dem neuen impfstoff
zu tun was können sie dazu sagen das ist
zum ersten mal eine einfache frage die
man beantworten kann weil die ersten
varianten von diesem virus wurden im
september schon entdeckt oder und und
die impfungen beginnen das jetzt gerade
das ich glaube da gibt es wirklich
keinen zusammenhang natürlich die frage
die sich stellt ist ob diese
virusvariante in irgendeiner form
unterschiedlich auf eine info reagiert
also zb der impfschutz vielleicht
geringer ist aber das ist teil von
laufenden forschungs aber ist das ist
das theoretisch möglich dass ich so
einen virus dann an die impfung anpasst
und dann quasi man sagen kann also ein
impfstoff hat dazu geführt dass ein
virus sich weiterentwickelt hat und dann
eben nicht mehr von diesem impfstoff
quasi bekämpft werden kann
ich würde mal einschränken unter
bestimmten bedingungen ja und zwar
normalerweise funktioniert impfstoffe
und auch diese rna impfstoffe die jetzt
gerade zugelassen wurden heute in der eu
auch die basieren darauf dass man das
immunsystem aktiviert ging eine ganze
reihe an zielstrukturen sogenannte
epitope in dem fall von den rna viren
von bayerns ex und moderner ist es im
prinzip das ganze ist ein protein das
sind 1200 meter sollen die scene in
diesem impfstoff enthalten und in diesem
spot ihn sind und sicher ich kann es
nicht genau beziffern man weiß dass wir
noch nicht aber das sind eine ganze
reihe betroffen vorhanden
10-20 wahrscheinlich deutlich mehr und
alle diese etappe für sich stimulieren
die immunantwort und zusammen bewirken
den schutz
das heißt in diesem szenario ist es
relativ unwahrscheinlich dass eine
einzelne mutation dazu führt dass die
vakzine nicht mehr effektiv ist wenn man
jetzt aber zum beispiel mit einem
einzigen antikörper versuchen wir dazu
immunisieren oder eine vakzin baut die
nur ein einziges epitope hält dann ist
die wahrscheinlichkeit extremst hoch
dass aufgrund von dem selektionsdruck
der dann nur auf diesem gebiet ohb
lastet das virus gezwungen ist zu skaten
also dieser antwort ist selektionsdruck
zu entkommen so immer das auch zum
beispiel der resistenz bildungen bei hiv
monotherapie kennt und das ist der grund
warum diese vakzine auf möglichst viele
verschiedene virus mutation getrimmt
werden
das ist sicher ein punkt der hier gibt
es nochmal einverständnis fragen kann
man relativ grundlegende von daniela
caro auf facebook wie kann ein virus das
unter freiem himmel menschen auf einem
wochenmarkt durch eine maske anfällt
also
das ist ein szenario es gibt ja sehr
viel mehrere infektion szenario wie kann
so ein virus noch ansteckender werden
ich glaube der begriff infektiosität ist
auch ein sehr schwer zu definierende im
labor kann man sagen ist relativ einfach
da dann nimmt man zellen in einer
petrischale schmeißt das virus drauf und
schaut einen halben tag später wieviel
virus ist in die zellen eingedrungen und
ist wieder rausgekommen das ist quasi
infektiosität in vitro in der zellkultur
in der petrischale in der menschen
population ist das deutlich schwieriger
und da muss man sich zum beispiel
behelfen damit dass man in biologisch
auswertet ob manche varianten sich
besser durchsetzen
und da kann man verschiedenste
mechanismen denken weder das sein könnte
ich gebe anhaltspunkte zum beispiel
spielt eine rolle in welchen zellen das
virus ein trick und repliziert wenn das
virus eher im oberen restaurations trakt
in der nasenschleimhaut zum beispiel ein
trick ist das vielleicht eher eine
leichtere erkrankung aber dafür ist es
einfacher dieses virus wieder in die
luft zu blasen wohingegen wenn das virus
bevorzugt in der lunge in den tiefen und
branchen repliziert ist das vielleicht
so ein schwert mit einer schweren
erkrankung assoziiert aber nicht mit
einer besonders starken verbreitung und
so gibt es verschiedene weitere aspekte
inklusive wie das virus mit dem
immunsystem integriert wie gut das virus
an die an den rezeptor an der oberfläche
der zellen andocken kann und
verschiedene weitere aspekte wo man
überall sicherlich immer noch weiter das
optimieren kann auf virus sei quasi noch
infektiöser zu werden
das muss ich mal kurz auf die
kommentatoren und auf einige
kommentatoren hier eingehen die uns
panikmache vorwerfen das hören wir immer
wieder aus den kommentaren das möchte
ich doch wirklich zurückweisen wir
versuchen hier sachlich aufzuklären um
eben keine panik aufkommen zu lassen
und wir haben gerade schon gehört
herbert seiler von der österreichischen
akademie der wissenschaften ist genau
einer derjenigen der sagt diese neue
virus mutation ist vielleicht nicht
wirklich so gefährlich
der professor draußen hat sich dem ja
auch angeschlossen oder andersrum erst
zuerst gesagt herr becker hat sich
angeschlossen also es ist jetzt nicht
unbedingt panik im raum vorsicht hat
herr lauterbach gesagt sollte man
vielleicht trotzdem haben deswegen
wurden ja auch viele grenzen dicht
gemacht eben unter anderem wegen dieser
hohen ansteckungsgefahr des johnson der
ministerpräsident von großbritannien hat
ja gesagt es gibt 70 prozent anstatt
muss quote ungefähr gibt es dafür eine
wissenschaftliche quelle dies zumindest
mir nicht bekannt er hat gesprochen dass
diese neue variante eines 70 prozent
höhere infektiosität hat so haben meines
wissens wurde das hochgerechnet von
epidemiologischen modellen man hat quasi
geschaut wie schnell hat sich diese
variante seit september ausgebreitet und
hat dann verglichen wie es viel
infektionen gab es aufgrund von anderen
varianten und dabei kann man auf diese
zahl von 70 prozent
die kann stimmen die kann auch
zusammenhänge mit den mutationen die
kann aber genauso gut den zufall
unterworfen sein also ich glaube da muss
man sehr vorsichtig sein und da ist noch
nicht wirklich zumindestens von
wissenschaftlicher seite geklärt ob das
diese variante auch tatsächlich
infektiöser ist also wir haben ganz
viele fragezeichen auf seiten der
wissenschaft trotzdem hat die politik
jetzt doch schon relativ drastisch
reagiert in der ganzen eu ich habe mich
so ein bisschen gefragt wenn wir jetzt
zwar davon ausgehen dass diese virus
mutation ansteckender ist aber
vielleicht nicht so einen schweren
verlauf hat wo es dann das problem auf
den ersten blick kann man sagen
unterstehen natürlich auch ein virus das
einfach nur infektiöser ist aber sonst
keine krankheit verursacht das tut uns
nicht weiter weh oder aber man muss sich
auch vor augen führen zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt zumindest haben wir doch eine
relativ starke rahmen der hohe rate an
schweren erkrankungen und 0,2 bis 0,4
prozent an mortalität dh zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt wo wir unsere grüne haben
bevölkerungen nicht schützen können
durch impfungen durch anderweitige
schutzschilde ist natürlich jede weitere
infektion birgt auch das risiko dass es
dabei dann in weiterer folge zu einer
schweren erkrankung kommt wir haben vor
einer guten stunde hier im zdf oder
nicht im zdf aber im fernsehen zdf mit
gesundheitsminister sparen gesprochen
und haben wir mal gefragt was jetzt
eigentlich der grund dafür ist dass die
grenzen dicht gemacht wurden dass auch
in deutschland keine flugzeuge mehr
landen dürfen
heute abend und er hat uns dass sie
gesagt und als vorsichtsmaßnahme haben
wir uns entschieden alles zu tun um
einen möglichen eintrag nach
kontinentaleuropa zu unterbinden
deswegen die unterbrechung des
flugverkehrs als vorsichtsmaßnahme wie
gesagt und gleichzeitig sind wieder
beiden engen austausch mit den
europäischen partnern auch zu schauen ob
und in welchem umfang ist diese variante
auch schon den kontinental europa
gegeben hat das ist auch dort alles
unter kontrolle ist
da stellt sich die frage ob wir in
europa in deutschland überhaupt dafür
ausgerüstet sind denn ihr kollege
herbert virologe jörg timm vom
universitätsklinikum düsseldorf der hat
heute kritisiert dass es in deutschland
keine systematische überwachung für
zirkulierende saß kopf zwei varianten
gibt also das gar nicht genau geguckt
wird wie die sich verändern er sagte im
zitat es gibt bemühungen aus einzelnen
laboren aber es fehlt eine klare
struktur und vor allem die finanziellen
mittel für eine bundesweite untersuchung
von virusvarianten ist das jetzt ein
deutsches problem oder das ist ein
europäisches problem und nur die briten
machen das gut
ich glaube es ist schon ein thema das
man europäisch habe bis jetzt nicht
wirklich gelöst hat es gibt manche
länder die sehr viel sequenzieren dazu
gehört england aber pro kopf sind die
dänen noch besser dran
die domodedowo über zwölf ich habe zehn
prozent oder so aller positiven fälle
von denen sie bis jetzt auch sequenziert
worden erstaunlicherweise und da stimme
ich überein den befund dass stimme die
aus deutschland sequenziert wurden die
finden sich in der internationalen
datenbanken fast gar nicht oder
verhältnismäßig wenig für das für die
anzahl der bevölkerungen auch im prinzip
für die für den forschungsstandort und
eigentlich dass das gut finanziert ist
in deutschland mein eindruck war dass es
zum teil auch mit rechtlichen
bedingungen zu tun hat dass diese
sequenzen nicht vielleicht öffentlich
gemacht werden können
ich kann nicht sagen in österreich sieht
es so aus dass wir im märz haben uns
dazu entschlossen haben quasi diese
lücke zu füllen und wir haben dabei ein
kollaborationsplattform gebildet
ausgehend vom forschungszentrum für
molekulare medizin der us akademie der
wissenschaften in wien aber auch der
medizinischen universität wien
und auch der österreichischen agentur
für gesundheit und ernährungssicherheit
das ist quasi eine eine staatliche
behörde die uns unterstützt aber ich sag
mal von behördenseite wird auch in
österreich aus nicht sequenziert wir
haben mittlerweile unterstützung von den
behörden die wirst mir sequenzieren was
ihr für sie virus genommen und aus
unserer hand kommen zurzeit mehr als 98
prozent aller viren die in österreich
sequenziert wurden aber das heißt es
könnte sein dass diese virus mutation
vor der ja zu gewarnt wird eigentlich
schon den ganz europa unterwegs ist aber
die briten weise halt besser nachschauen
wie welche mutation vorliegt da ist
jetzt nachweisen konnten und ihn quasi
deswegen die grenzen dicht gemacht
wurden
das könnte so sein tatsächlich ich
glaube es gibt mittlerweile einige
länder inklusive holland in italien wo
auch diese varianten schon sequenziert
wurden und identifiziert wurden
ich kann ihnen sagen dass wir zum
beispiel in österreich heute mit den
behörden wurden von den letzten
flugzeugen aus england wurden die
passagiere quasi freiwillig gebeten ob
sie nicht proben abgeben wollen und wenn
da positive darunter sind sequenzieren
wird dies in den nächsten tagen aber ich
glaube die wahrscheinlichkeit ist ist
schon vorhanden dass diese variante auch
schon in österreich wahrscheinlich auch
schon in deutschland sieht befindet
die grenzen sind natürlich nicht zu
starr zwischen länder- und gerade in
europa insofern ich würde fast davon
ausgehen aber wir haben noch keine
evidenz dass es auch tatsächlich so ist
ehrensache ich an dieser stelle vielen
dank für ihre einschätzungen
informationen und den basis grundkurs
virologie den wir alle immer noch immer
weiter nötig haben ich danke ihnen
herzlichen dank die situation in
großbritannien ist seit bekanntwerden
dieser neuen virus variante ja doch
relativ angespannt seit gestern wird der
grenzverkehr von und mit uk von immer
mehr ländern eingeschränkt da kommt es
dann zu wirklich schwierigen situationen
hier in deutschland ist ein kurz nach
acht die letzte maschine aus
großbritannien gelandet deutsche
passagiere müssen in quarantäne
britische werden getestet noch am
flughafen um sicher zu gehen dass sie
nicht positiv sind und in den häfen gab
es kilometerlange staus oder gibt es bis
jetzt immer noch schon seit tagen
seitdem frankreich gestern
grenze nach großbritannien dichtgemacht
hat für mindestens 48 stunden herrscht
wirklich das pure chaos wir sehen hier
sehr sehr lange lkw schlangen an der
britische zeitung titelte empört europa
schlägt großbritannien die tür zu
darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit
meiner kollegin diana zimmermann in
london
die natürlich das ganze ja tatsächlich
selber am eigenen leib zu spüren bekommt
die uk ist so gut wie abgeregelt wie ist
denn jetzt die stimmung bei euch im land
es fühlt sich ein bisschen einsam an her
auf der insel mit einem rotierenden
virus die briten sind ziemlich
schockiert über die reaktionen der
umliegenden länder vor allen dingen vor
allen dingen mit diesem französischen
gefragt der französischen fragt blockade
haben sie eigentlich nicht gerechnet und
die wut die sich hier langsam gegenüber
der regierung auf stadt ist doch
erheblich denn der premier es eben in
den vergangenen monaten vor allen dingen
durch massive kehrtwenden aufgefallen
und dadurch dass er im schnitt sehr spät
gehandelt hat das sind jetzt die
direkten auswirkungen also kann man das
schon spüren
gibt es jetzt weniger fischen chips oder
weniger grün waren also obst und gemüse
die ja nicht mehr kaufen könnt also die
direkten auswirkungen sind erstmal die
das heute 30.000 touristen an
irgendwelchen flughafen festsassen weil
die flüge gecancelt worden und die
anderen hast du ja schon angesprochen
das sind die langen staus in staus in
dover die gab es schon vorher weil sich
sämtliche britische unternehmen vor
allen dingen aber die supermärkte auf
erhebliche störungen der lieferkette in
der praxis übergangsphase also während
des wechsels stattfindet eingestellt
haben und massiv aufgestockt haben ihre
lagerbestände so dass schon in den
letzten tagen sehr sehr lange staus 20
meilen langen staus rund um dörfer und
kanäle waren die sind jetzt natürlich
noch viel länger geworden
die lastwagenfahrer sind wütend denn sie
sitzen erstens fest und die europäischen
kommen wahrscheinlich an weihnachten
nicht mehr rechtzeitig zurück die
frischen waren in den lastwagen
verderben und die stimmung insgesamt ist
da natürlich wirklich ganz besonders
schlecht es gibt es eine interessante
frage gefunden
maldonado auf youtube der grenzverkehr
wird eingeschränkt obwohl seit september
bekannt ist dass es diese neue
virusvariante gibt also da erschließt
sich für eben diese zeitleiste quasi
nicht so richtig ja es war bekannt dass
es eine mutation gibt so habe ich das
zumindest verstanden hat ja auch der
experte gerade nochmal gesagt aber es
war nicht bekannt dass die so viel
ansteckender ist
dazu sagte boris johnson in seiner
pressekonferenz heute am frühen abend
eben dass sie das wirklich erst seit
freitagnachmittag christen und da hätten
sie dann eben ganz besonders schnell
reagiert wie hat es die britische
regierung versucht diese ja muss man ja
sagen erneute katastrophe ihren bürgern
zu verkaufen indem sie sagen die
sachlage habe sich geändert und sie
müssten reagieren auf das was die panda
mieten pandemien diktiert hier heißt es
die ganze zeit sie folgte neben den
ratschlägen der wissenschaft und die
wissenschaft hat sich am freitag
dahingehend geändert dass man gesagt hat
das ist sehr gefährlich
die inzidenz dieses neuen virus deutet
darauf hin dass es sich rasant schnell
verbreitet und für diese große welle an
neuinfektionen die wir hier beobachten
einen großen anteil an verantwortung
trägt und so wurde das erklärt es war
allerdings wirklich ganz besonders
bitter für boris johnson
dennoch letzte woche den
oppositionsführer als unmenschlich
bezeichnet hat weil der sagte
weihnachten müsse eigentlich abgesagt
werden johnson hat sich wirklich richtig
reingekniet heute den briten wirklich
sehr gerne ein schönes weihnachtsfest
bescheren
das ganze passt auch gut zu seinem bild
von einem liberalen großzügigen
regierungschef und nun musste er so kurz
vor weihnachten das ganze absagen die
haushalte die sich treffen dürfen massiv
reduzieren man darf nun einen menschen
hier treffen in weiten teilen des landes
und das ganze sorgt neben tatsächlich
für ver größten unmut
also hier kommen wir mal fragen
tatsächlich zu ihr den zusammenhang den
zeitlichen zusammenhang haben wir gerade
schon versucht zu erklären
es war bekannt dass es eine virus
mutation gab seit september
ansteckend die tatsächlich sein könnte
und wie viel sie sich verbreitet hat
gerade den süden englands ist erst in
den letzten tagen bekannt geworden
deswegen hat die britische regierung
jetzt auch sich zu drastischen schritten
entschlossen die gibt es aber auch
fragen zb von jim thaler hat die
einschränkung des reiseverkehrs und
großbritannien etwas mit dem brand zu
tun ist es vielleicht so etwas wie eine
rache der eu-staaten für den exit dass
man die briten jetzt schon mal spüren
lassen möchte guck mal so könnte das ab
ersten januar aussehen auch ohne krone
virus ja dann kann man nicht
ausschließen und wie wir ja eben wie wie
du ja eben schon vorgelesen hat aus der
britischen zeitung wird dass hier
durchaus auch so ein bisschen so
aufgenommen und hochgepusht es ist sehr
pikant tatsächlich dass die
direktverhandlungen momentan wohl vor
allen dingen am fisch stocken einen
wirtschaftlich komplett unbedeutenden
zweig der aber politisch wahnsinnig
aufgeladen ist und da verhaken sich die
franzosen und die briten denen geht es
eben wie man darum wie man jetzt die
fischerei aufteilt und dass die
franzosen sehr schnell gesagt haben sie
würden jetzt auch den frachtverkehr so
massiv einschränken wird auch von dieser
seite hier so gewertet als sei das eine
kleine rache aktion oder eine
vorsichtige andeutung dessen was da noch
kommen könnte und anderer seien sie
natürlich der verkehr zwischen richter
die alte fehde zwischen großen hallen
und frankreich wieder auf also keine eu
streit ohne großbritannien oder britisch
französischen streit das scheint sich
jetzt auch hier wieder zu bewahrheiten
könnte man vielleicht auch andersrum
denken dass boris johnson versucht jetzt
dieses diese neue variante zu nutzen um
die ja wirklich schwierige lage im land
doch generell zu versuchen aber
kontrolle zu kriegen und dann quasi eine
argumentation zu haben warum weihnachten
quasi in uk dieses jahr fast ausfällt
ja die diese theorie wirbelt die hier
sehr schnell hoch und sie zeigt meiner
ansicht nach vor allem erst mal wie
wenig vertrauen der premier in teilen
der bevölkerung genießt dass man ihm
tatsächlich unterstellt dass er die
gesamte welt in angst und schrecken
versetzen um innenpolitisch ein paar
punkte zu machen und ein kleines
bisschen besser auszusehen bei seiner
dicksten kehrtwende
er hat davon schon so viele hingelegt
dass diese jetzt eigentlich auch keinen
großen unterschied mehr macht also das
ist eine wie ich finde sehr gewagte
these die beinhalten würde das die
briten tatsächlich sich überhaupt nicht
darüber im klaren sind wie aufmerksam
verfolgt wird was auch hier passiert und
die in kauf nimmt dass ihnen eben selbst
jetzt massiver kurzfristiger schaden
entsteht eben durch diese ganzen reise
und fracht beschränkungen
ich halte das für nicht sehr
wahrscheinlich dass er das vielleicht
ein bisschen hoch gespielt hat auch um
klar zu machen auch wenn wir nicht ganz
genau wissen wie stark jetzt die
infektionszahlen wirklich mit dem neuen
virus zusammenhängen dass das alles nur
deswegen so gekommen ist das ist
natürlich schon vielleicht eine reaktion
darauf dass eben der oppositionsführer
ihm schon seit wochen sagt seine idee
weihnachten relativ in ruhe zu lassen
seine sehr schlechte und viel zu
gefährlich bei den zahlen die wir hier
beobachten
bist du denn jetzt endlich gut versorgt
über weihnachten hast du schon beim
weihnachtsbraten eingekauft und müssen
wir uns sorgen machen
das thema weihnachten
er griff bekommt wir haben wir haben den
weihnachtsbraten und einen sauerteig zu
hause mit dem wir uns ein brot backen ok
dann will ich bin ich froh dass du
zumindest versorgt ist und nicht
stundenlang noch vor irgendwelchen
supermärkten anstehen muss wir haben ja
auch schon schlimme bilder heute gesehen
und wir hoffen dass sich die lage nicht
entspannen vielen dank jana zimmermann
für diese einschätzungen aus dem
vereinigten königreich aber das bitte
bleib gesund und das wünsche ich auch
natürlich heute und ihnen im stream
passt auf euch auf passen aber passen
sie auf sich auf abstand halten ist
immer noch die beste regel dann die wir
uns halten sollten die wir empfehlen
können
und ansonsten ruhig bleiben eben keine
panik schieben das wollen wir auch hier
nichts und das versuchen wir wirklich
jedes mal zu vermeiden
heute sage ich aber erst mal machen wir
den laden hier dicht wir sehen uns
morgen bestimmt wieder mit einem neuen
thema unter dem neuen stream bis dahin
macht gut und schießen